Sorry, the mic... threw off my groove.
Hi!
Can I finish my banana real quick?
What if I said something else?
Everybody eat banana, it's good for potassium.
Banana at 7pm?
Is that bad?
Is this how I won't stop copying?
How do you know I'm not having yours?
I didn't know I didn't just have... I didn't just possess your mind and your body and eat your banana and took it.
Now I'm eating it.
Da!
Stole the banana, exactly.
I think it thinks that the banana peel is 6.7% Hold on
I just ate a rotten part of the banana I just bought this banana I wasn't looking and I ate into it No!
Hold on, let me read some of the superchats As they are coming in, thank you for the superchats!
Thank you!
I was watching your Miisai VOD and would like to volunteer to be your GF.
I will cook, not jump scare you.
Let you do all the haunting.
I need a little bit of a jump scare.
Brown and soft is still fine.
That's what you make pudding with.
Really?
Wait, it's okay then?
I'll be well today.
I used to play this game on my phone a lot.
I am good.
I also used to play it on my phone.
Taxman is coming.
Oh gosh, don't remind me.
I don't even want to think about it.
Banana?
Mr. Bandai, thank you for the 20 Gifted.
Help me with your nanomachines.
I will.
And Ducky, thanks for the Gifted.
Okay.
Mintophilioma.
Use code Boomer.
Andrew, thanks for the 20 Gifted.
Thank you!
Actually, today has been like... my brain is not working today.
I had an appointment.
And I put it in my calendar for 3 PM.
Sorry, 3.30 PM.
But it was actually 3 PM.
So I was 30 minutes late.
And then I got there.
And they were like...
It was like... I say an appointment.
It was a facial.
I make it sound so official.
No, it was just...
But then they were like...
Do you have any medicines?
And I was like... No.
And then I was like... Wait a second.
Yes.
And I was like...
I was like...
I have the medicine.
I've been taking the medicine.
And so then I couldn't even get the thing that I had my appointment for.
And I was...
It ended up taking what should have been like a 30 minute appointment.
It took 2 hours.
My brain is not working today.
But that's okay.
Because all we have to do is infect the world.
What are we going to do tonight, Minto?
The same thing we do every night.
We try to take over the world.
We tried after ink from the same devs.
Not the cure one, right?
Is that something else?
I haven't actually.
Wait a second.
Minky and the brain.
That's implying that I'm not the brain.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no.
Change the...
Change the lyrics.
No, no, no.
Minky has a brain.
Minky is the brain.
She has the brain.
And is a little insane.
Canon lyrics.
Pinky is the emotionally intelligent one.
I don't know if I'm even that.
Too late, canon now.
No.
Minky has something, alright.
What do you mean by that?
What do you... Can you say...
I think I did it too...
Oh, sorry.
Oh gosh.
I think I did it too well.
It even surprised me.
Oh my god.
Oh no...
I have tears in my eyes.
My mouth doesn't open though.
When I eat... It used to open.
But now when I eat food I'm like...
I'm like a proper lady.
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
One time I accidentally drank rotten...
Palm green tea.
It was fermented and had black stuff in it.
I didn't notice at first because I'm used to kombucha.
I've never had kombucha before.
Johnny!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Johnny H.
Happy birthday!
Which do you guys prefer?
Do you guys prefer when the VTuber goes...
Or do you prefer when the VTuber goes...
Which do you prefer?
I will start chewing with my mouth open.
Oh gosh.
Can you imagine?
There's some habits from VTubing that I have taken off stream as well.
And I can imagine if I was just like...
Well, if everybody wants me to chew with my mouth open...
Because they like it better.
I feel that it would permanently change how I eat.
And my friends would be like...
Mint, you're disgusting.
What are you doing?
And I'm like... I would form such a bad habit.
Logan, thank you for the vibe gift.
All the time.
Instead.
Instead!
Sorry, chat liked it more.
I'm just a monkey that dances for you guys.
I don't have any more food.
Actually, that's a lie.
I have some candy, but I don't want candy.
I don't want a candy just to show you guys how I chew.
Dog with peanut butter vibes.
VTuber, eat peanut butter.
Both are adorable?
Really?
You think so?
It's my birthday.
Don't ask how old.
But thanks for the AOE to stream yesterday.
Let's just say I played that game as a high schooler.
Happy birthday, Old Serge.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Can you chew...
Can you chew me with two?
I want to get smothered.
I think it turned auto-correct off.
I have auto-correct turned back on.
And then I made a tweet about it earlier.
I was typing it and I typed...
Initially I was typing big announcement.
And then I typed bug.
And then I spelled announcement wrong.
I forgot an N.
Bug announcement.
Is it just me or is Minto looking extra cute today?
Was that the Minto virus taking over your brain?
What are you talking...
I look the same that I do everyday.
Oh my gosh, but...
I saw something today.
I saw something today that you guys will see eventually.
Actually I saw two things today.
That you guys will see eventually.
That are very...
Very cute.
Very cute, I think.
Minto I choose you.
You is a tail wag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Big things coming.
Chewing for viewers, but we're off stream.
What do you mean?
Sorry if the BGM cuts out from the game it's because I tabbed out of the window.
It's one of those types of games, you know what I mean?
My defense, no!
Lower defense, lower defense, lower defense.
Are you guys ready to spread some brain rot?
All over...
Multiplayer?
It's my friend and fellow wisp's birthday today.
Can I get an MGS birthday for my friend Chuwu?
That's actually his name.
Wait, did I say it right then?
Chuwu?
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your scars stay blue!
Happy birthday Chuwu!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Two plagues.
I imagine it's probably like a friend multiplayer.
I thought you could be like multiple, multiple, multiple player.
Let's do the main game.
Play.
I think I remember how to play this.
The following new plague type has been discovered and unlocked.
Shadow Plague.
In single player.
I was at MAGFest over the weekend and there were so many wisps and sold out mint fan art.
Gamers love mint.
I didn't even know MAGFest was happening and then I saw that it was happening and I was like...
I feel FOMO.
I was like...
Oh yeah, Matara was there.
Thank god I didn't go.
It was so funny.
She sent me a picture of her with a snake cosplay.
She was like, look I found him.
I was like, that's my man!
And then she went, no, it's my man.
And sent me another picture of her doing heart hands with him.
I was like, you planned this.
She doesn't even know him.
It's Naked Snake.
I was like, what the hell?
How dare you plan this?
How dare you?
How dare?
Am I so predictable that she would knew I say, it's my little man.
And then she...
I hate this.
I did.
I did get fiddled.
I did get played like a damn fiddle.
Snake would never love me anyway.
I don't think he would love Matara either, not gonna lie.
He would be...
I mean, maybe he would be attracted to her looks and then she'd open her mouth and never shut it.
And he'd be like, okay, nevermind.
I think he'd... I can imagine her just being yap, yap, yapping away.
And he's just like...
Like trying to sleep.
You know like a montage of someone who just never shuts up.
And he's like, he's like rolling over in bed trying to cover his ears with his pillow and she's just non-stop yapping.
I'm gonna play the game alongside you and see if your strategy will help me win as well.
You got to re-infect her with the brain rot.
I know, she has to finish.
I hosted a minto watch party at MAG, it was super fun.
Wait, I saw the picture!
Why didn't you invite me?
TFT on.
You're gonna host a minto party and not even invite me?
Hekate, thanks for 9 months!
Thank you!
I didn't know they had mint in this game.
Would you go?
Yeah, I'd haunt.
I would like be there in spirit.
They were busy streaming.
Fine, everybody gets to go and have fun and you know, hang out.
And I'll... I'll play Plague Inc.
Ha, I get it.
I'm so... I'm so... I'm a fungus.
Or you could say I'm a fungi.
Where's the vampire?
We could be a monkey!
Or we could be a vampire.
Sentient.
Mutant.
I remember trying this one before.
The Shadow Plague is actually really difficult.
Because...
It's hard.
It's kind of complicated.
I don't know the strats for it.
How hard?
If you hard, then you hard.
Shadow Plague.
Exactly.
Just like that.
Maybe we just... Let's take it slow.
Let's take it slow with the bacteria.
Oh gosh.
Okay, we got to get the genes in.
Oh, I don't have any genes.
Everything's locked.
We must unlock the things first.
We have zero genes unlocked.
Let's do it.
We'll do normal.
67.3% of people wash hands.
Doctors work three days a week.
That's it.
Sick people ignore.
Ignore.
That's so mean.
No apple bottom jeans.
No boots with the fur.
Hope my favorite ghost maid is doing well today.
I am.
Thanks, Amanda.
Okay.
Let the sick people be ignored.
Actually, I'm sick and I'm ignored.
I'm sick with Metal Gear Brain Rot.
Wait, cheats?
Dang.
No cheats allowed.
Let's name it.
The Brain Rot.
This is not your average virus, everybody.
This is literally the Metal Gear Brain Rot.
This is literally the Metal Gear.
I go into your home and I say, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear.
And then you become terminal with the Metal Gear Brain Rot.
We aren't ignoring you.
There's just no treatment.
You guys, last night... I have a confession.
Well, this has happened before, but it also happened last night and that's why it's fresh in my brain.
Some nights I can't sleep.
You'll see me that I'm on Twitter maybe at like 2 AM EST.
3 AM EST.
And last night was one of those nights.
I actually wasn't on Twitter, though.
And those nights, those nights I can't sleep, it's because I'm literally thinking about Snake and Ocelot.
And last night, I was just bawling my little eyes out.
I was just thinking about them.
And thinking about how tragic their love is.
And thinking about how...
I can't.
Why is my OTP also not so popular?
Everybody likes Snake Otacon, but nobody likes Snake...
They like Venom Ocelot.
My OTP...
There's just something so beautiful.
It's because I'm dead, you know?
That's why I love a tragic love story, because everything that I would have is tragic, because I'm dead.
So I think maybe that's why I'm just like, yeah, give me that tragic love that they'll never get together.
You're such a lose... lose arm.
Says you.
Why'd you put that space there, huh?
Wait, if you put loser, does it get...
Does it get caught by the YouTube of gods?
More of a Snake Miller kind of guy.
That's fine too.
But, you know, I just love Big Boss and Otacon.
So, nope, just kidding.
Ocelot, oh gosh.
Now I'm thinking of Otacon.
You should repost more fan art of them and then maybe you'll infect us.
No, it's for my eyes only.
Sometimes love can't bloom on a battlefield.
It did!
No, it did!
I ship Ocelot, SniperWolf, like a real degenerate.
The brain rot.
Welcome to Plague Inc.
You are a new bacteria.
To win, you must evolve and spread across the world, wiping out all humans in the ultimate plague.
The ultimate plague of brain rot.
Everybody, when you say dead, don't think of them as actually dead.
They are just thinking of their OTP too much.
And they're thinking about Metal Gear too much, you know.
Oh my goodness.
Loud BGM, sorry.
Dead inside.
No!
Don't dead, open inside.
Guys, I also have a confession today.
Today I played Bellatro.
I played more Bellatro and I died.
And I also played more Age of Empires.
Bellatro mentioned.
Where should we start?
Wait.
Alaska?
Can I start in Alaska?
Or should I start in the Russian jungles?
Madagascar.
I did that before.
I did that last time.
Greenland?
No, it's so... We gotta get there naturally.
Zanzibar.
Zanzibar land is not a real place.
Antarctica.
I don't think you can go there.
Can you?
We can't start in Antarctica.
There's people there though.
They're the only safe ones.
It's real to me.
Let's start.
Let's start in the Russian jungles.
That's where the story begins, everybody.
That's where Metal Gear begins, in the Russian jungles.
It's huge!
Does this virus affect me if my brain is already soup?
I slurped it?
BGM is still loud?
Is that butter?
I feel like...
All my settings have been off lately.
Yummy.
Cherry!
Thanks for 9 months!
Thank you!
Better?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
We're here.
The brain rot begins in Russia.
The brain rot has infected its first human.
Weak, but not... used to cold temperatures and must evolve using DNA points to invade more people.
Awesome life!
It's too good.
Okay, so from here is how you...
Oh wait, hold on.
How do I...
We have one person infected.
Oh, we get DNA points.
I think she was really looking forward to cracking up today.
I'm looking forward to cracking up.
I love that video.
I haven't cracked up in a while.
I'm really looking forward to cracking up.
Stop it!
Let's see.
Maybe we have 10 points.
Maybe...
Oh, CQC!
CQC...
is...
is probably the best way, right?
BQB.
Ebola.
I used to...
It took me one time reading the Hot Zone...
for me to become such a big fan of Ebola.
I had a little Ebola plushie.
All I did was read the Hot Zone once and I was like...
That's my virus!
Fan.
Let's see.
How much...
Cost 8.
Evolve.
BQB.
You have successfully evolved the Brain Rot.
Fan.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Fan of what?
You know, just how it is.
How it's so horrible.
You know?
How, like, you bleed everywhere.
How...
How it's just such a...
funky virus.
And it's just...
It's virus looks like a little worm.
You know?
Eating Mike Tyson's...
booty hole.
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you.
I'm gonna change it to something different every time.
Okay.
We're traveling.
We have 4 infected.
This is the slow...
This might be...
This might be a slow...
Wait.
A slow game.
But we'll get there.
Thanks for 7 months.
Thank you!
Valve time slower than thought.
Researchers have calculated that it takes longer than expected for radioactive fluids with a half-life of 3 years to pass through valves.
Reason?
Unknown.
The brain rot begins to spread.
Half-life 3 reference.
Thanks for the super chat, Lizzo!
Valve out, you're catching strays.
The brain rot begins to spread.
Spreading from person to person in rush hour will grow exponentially.
You control the plague indirectly by evolving it.
Nice.
Okay, what else can we do?
We can do some abilities.
I think abilities are probably the more important thing, right?
Able to withstand hot temperature and climate.
But we already know we can withstand cold temperature and climate because we're in...
We're in the...
The jungle.
You control the brain rot.
We will get GTA 6 before half-life 3.
Valve has the opportunity to do the funniest thing right now.
They have the opportunity to do the silliest, funniest thing.
The jungle's in rush hour, what?
Sorry, it's Metal Gear.
Sorry, it's Metal Gear reference.
Look, look, look!
It's Metal Gear, it's Metal Gear.
I'm sorry.
I'll shut up about Metal Gear.
Powering off.
What is that?
Is that a blood thing?
It's just anemia.
Blood disease.
Okay, okay.
Without the points.
Let's go.
I guess, let's see.
Resistant to antibiotics.
Shell to protect against all climates.
Keep on spreading.
To find out more about a country...
Oh my gosh!
You can zoom in, I had no idea.
The brain rot infects hundreds!
That's us, you guys.
That's us.
They can make a Half-Life 3 musical if they're brave.
Maybe.
Spreading the IE tiger virus.
Oh my gosh.
I had a dream last night that...
I had a dream last night that I was showing off my books.
And this is real.
This is real.
Like, this is what friends do when you are into otake and stuff.
Also, no Nelson, I'm sorry.
Hold on.
How many points do you need to get the brain rot to unlock anime VTubers?
And waifu figurines.
That's free, that's free.
But anyway, my dream last night.
I was showing off my books that my friends have gotten me.
Because I rearranged my room the other day.
And I was looking at my books and I was like...
Oh, my books!
Wait, hold on.
I have... Hold on, let me go get it.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I thought I had one more.
But my friends...
My friends got me these books so many years ago.
And now I'm making my dream a reality.
My actual dream.
My dream that was in my head last night.
So my friends got me these books.
The first one is called Meet the Tiger.
It's just a book all about tigers.
But it's so funny that it's called Meet the Tiger.
Because if you don't know anything about otage.
Which are like the loud calling and cheers and everything.
Hi!
The people do like idol concerts and stuff like that.
There's one that's...
You know, there's the one mix that goes...
And then there's also like...
And then...
We're all just like...
So...
It's funny that it's called Meet the Tiger.
And then my friends also got me another book.
And this one's the best one.
I don't even know anything that it's about.
But it's called The Tiger in the House!
Oh my god!
It's called The Tiger...
The Tiger in the House is teeming with excitement.
And heart stirring emotion.
A natural storyteller.
Shihan will draw you in with her finely crafted characters.
And hold you tight until the very end.
So it's a literal house tiger!
Oh my gosh, it's so funny.
It's so fun...
I still have these.
I still have these because...
It's just...
You know, my friends got them for me.
Even though I've never read The Tiger in the House.
I literally only have it for the name.
And I have it on my bookshelf.
Thanks friends!
They don't watch my streams.
They don't watch my streams, but that's okay.
That's actually how I prefer it.
Kai!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Okay.
The brain rot is infecting hundreds.
Let's go.
You can shut up when you're dead.
Wait.
I am dead.
It's been nine months, time to take responsibility.
Uh...
Yeah, my responsibility.
Alright.
We gotta get into other countries.
What's going on now?
What's happening now?
Maybe we increase the transmission.
From the BQB.
So nasty.
Wait, refund?
Oh no, this isn't.
My bad.
Fourteen.
Infected bodily fluids able to pass through mucous membranes.
Meet the tiger.
Team Fortress 2 theme.
I actually don't know Team Fortress 2.
Still waiting on the album.
Please Minto, don't do this.
I don't want to go outside.
What do you mean?
Aihara, thanks for nine months.
Thank you.
King Zero, welcome to membership.
Let's do the BQB.
Guys, this isn't a normal bacteria.
This isn't a normal virus.
This is literal...
Think of it as like...
It's more like a...
It's a mental thing.
It's not a physical virus.
It's like...
This is literally...
Can I zoom out?
There we go.
This is the Metal Gear Brain Rot taking over.
Boo.
Thanks, Gator.
Festival of Love?
Wait, Russia celebrates the Festival of Love.
We're going to infect so many people with the Brain Rot.
Fans praise the replacement for International Kissing Day.
A Russian twat.
Wait.
It was supposed to be a kissing day and now it's not?
No.
Our transmission.
Critics question hygiene standards.
Wait.
So they are still kissing or...
It's been upgraded.
From just kissing to more love.
Not just kissing.
Handshakes?
And...
High-fives?
Hand-holding?
I have been birthed, Minky.
Happy birthday, Nick.
Minto, alimony and child support fund.
Thank you.
You never told me about the other...
Can't believe Minto created the original Brain Rot.
Must be Solid Snake breakdancing.
Sorry, I'm trying to read Super Chats.
And everybody.
But it's hard because of the game.
The Brain Rot infects thousands.
23,000.
Holy moly.
We need...
Once we get a little bit...
More people...
You know, then...
Then they'll realize...
Or rather, then we'll get the symptoms going, you know?
Then we'll get the symptoms going.
Doing some kind of judo.
Love giving my wife a handshake before we go to our separate beds.
I hear though that having separate beds is healthy.
We don't have enough DNA points.
Baltic states have been infected!
New infection!
Are you sure realization isn't a symptom?
No...
More countries are...
How?
How is it?
Oh, it's mutating!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
What is this?
What is this mutation?
Infection.
Let's do it also through the bugs.
Batara Khan plays Metal Gear.
Don't read...
Medicine in Germany slowing infection.
They already have a medicine?
No...
Medicine coat.
I have no money.
New aid program.
I thought it was... I thought it was... What's it called?
Oh my goodness.
How is it spreading so fast now?
What's happening?
The love festival!
The love festival.
Oh my god!
More infectious than TB.
It's a very infect... How is it?
How did Just Kissing do this?
How did Just Kissing do this to...
I think it just got sent to America.
I watched it.
I watched it take a boat there.
Ok, hold on.
We have the resistance.
And we have the resistance.
Nice.
This is the boss's will.
More infectious than HIV!
Extremely infectious.
The love festival really did numbers.
Guys...
Russia almost half brain rotted.
I know.
Russia is like only thinking about Metal Gear now.
New minor disease spreading.
In a normal checkup, a doctor in Russia found a new disease.
This world is freaking...
Should we start the freak disease too next?
Should we start the freak disease next?
Which has been named the brain rot.
It appears...
To be mostly harmless but must be investigated further.
Other countries are also reporting this disease.
Japan!
This is the boss's will.
Coughing symptom!
Hey, hey, hey.
Don't get too...
This guy is so...
He is so energetic.
People all over the world join hands.
Start a love train.
Love train.
Um...
Inability to sleep!
Ok, let's get rid of coughing.
Give me my points.
Yeah, yeah, devolve and get this one instead.
Oh no!
Uh-oh.
Russia starts work on a cure.
Love festival does this?
We need love deterrence.
Peace day!
Hi Minto, it was my birthday last week.
I don't know if I can still claim a song.
Either way, thank you for being such a cheerful giggly presence.
Atamama, happy birthday!
Gosh, they start working on the cure so fast.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Atamama.
Happy birthday!
Ok, how do we slow the cure?
How do we slow the cure?
Ok, it's still at 0%.
Evolve!
Infect more.
Metal gear, metal gear.
Everybody think about metal gear.
Everybody is thinking about metal gear right now.
Almost the entire world.
Nobody will ever stop thinking.
Genetic hardening and air.
Oh no!
I hope I got it.
Hold on, let's grab...
We got Greenland!
Wait, we don't have Iceland yet though.
But their borders are still...
Dang, I thought that was going straight there.
Oh we got Australia!
But no New Zealand.
We have nowhere in Africa.
Nowhere in South America.
Madagascar?
No.
We don't want people to close their borders.
That's when things really start.
That's why you don't want the symptoms to be too craziness.
Oh!
We hit Egypt?
We hit Iceland!
Cysts?
No, no, no.
I don't want that yet.
Where is the cysts?
This one?
Tumors?
Wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
Abscesses?
Give me my money.
Paranoia.
The brain rot compels people to watch the video of Mint singing Santa Baby.
You guys like that video so much.
Why do you guys like that video so much?
It's not a tumor.
We love it.
And I have to do like a...
What's the word?
Jazzy karaoke sometime soon.
But I don't think you guys will survive, maybe.
That's okay.
Oh, we are at 2%.
Oh, sorry.
We are at 2% though.
For the cure.
More infectious than the common cold.
Okay, we need to get Madagascar.
We need to get New Zealand.
How can I see what countries I have not infected yet?
I got Canada, just a tiny bit.
I think like almost all of South America.
Just kidding.
Press info on world?
This one?
Oh, thank you.
We still have a little bit.
Let's see.
Let's give... We have a lot of points.
Let's do an ability.
Decrease research?
Wait, I think we need more hot climate, perhaps.
And let's decrease the research.
Pathogen strand reassembled.
We don't want to survive.
We want you to kill us.
No!
Because I want you to have happy...
How else am I supposed to steal your life force if everybody dies?
How else am I supposed to survive if I...
If I am then hungry for life force?
You guys are so selfish.
How dare you not think about Minto2.
We are at 6% for the world.
For the cure.
7%!
Oh no!
The brain rot was placed on a watch list.
Oh my god, New Zealand!
Wait, I'm kind of blocking stuff a little bit.
Hold on.
Let me make myself smaller.
I apologize.
I'll put my arms down too.
Now it should be easier for you to see.
There you go.
Okay.
Still need Madagascar.
Nobody is going there.
Come on!
We still have just a few places.
Nausea.
No, no, no.
I don't... I still think we need to...
Where is the nausea here?
Devolve, devolve.
Let's do transmission.
Let's do maybe...
Maybe an insect.
More again.
I've lost because of Madagascar.
I know, me too.
Sick for 5 months.
Is this the long brain rot?
No!
Where did Mint go?
Who is this?
What are you talking about?
I can put my arms down.
I have hands.
Kind of.
Germany!
Oh no, Germany is leading the global cure effort.
No!
11%.
Pop the blue to stop the cure.
No cure!
Oh no, Germany shuts down.
We also need New Guinea.
Where else do we need?
There are still quite a few places.
Wait, I think we just got New Guinea.
Nice, we just got it.
No cure!
Brain rot awareness day!
Chat, why are her arms down like that?
Brain rot awareness day.
Charities are holding the brain rot awareness day to raise the profile of this disease and encourage development of a cure.
The brain rot will spread.
We got Madagascar!
Is that everybody?
Just a few more.
Morocco, Algeria.
Two more, two more, two more, two more.
Two more!
No, stop mutating.
Actually...
Pathogen uses host lymphocytes to replicate.
Increase infectivity.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's also... Abilities...
Let's uh...
Let's scramble, or scramble, or scramble.
Let's do some...
Maybe now we'll do water.
Infection!
Break, break, break, break, break, break.
Okay, the world's cure is only still at 22%.
And that is... everybody.
What happens if the brain rot can be...
No, it would not be that!
It would be...
It would be a... not that kind of transmission.
It would be like a... wait.
It would be a GTD.
A Game Transmitted Disease.
It's like, you know, the movie The Ring?
Ringu?
It's like that.
You play the game and you're infected.
You know, it's...
Oh, what was that?
25% complete!
Oh no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
Evolve!
And also, let's get...
Okay, paranoia.
And things.
Okay.
They're gonna...
Wind!
I'm the avatar!
Wind, water, bug, blood.
Those were the four elements.
Destroy.
24... 25%!
Oh no!
The brain rot needs to evolve to kill.
Okay.
Oh god!
Alright.
We must...
Inflammation!
Seizure!
Insanity!
Fight the cure.
We're fighting the cure!
The Philippines...
Has the first person that says...
I don't wanna be cured!
It's not a death, you guys.
It's the acceptance phase.
It's the acceptance phase where you say...
I don't wanna be cured!
I want this brain rot forever!
Forever!
It's not death!
It's, yeah, brain death.
How you say?
Yeah.
The first given salvation.
Madagascar, you can try.
Oh gosh.
Global research focused on the cure.
Okay.
Good.
We'll take the free money.
Or we'll take the free things.
They already know that we're here.
We're here to stay.
We're here... No!
No cure!
Oh gosh, is that 38%?
Holy cow.
Okay, we need to...
Coughing!
Coughing, rash...
I hate the creepy children.
Slight chance of infection when kissing.
What's up with the kissing?
Pretty sure that's death, man.
You're just forcing us to visit you in the afterlife forever.
No!
Focus on lethal.
I don't have enough money.
We'll get more money.
We'll get more DNA points.
Oh my gosh, it's going up so fast!
Tokyo Olympics mystery.
Mystery still surrounds the decision to postpone the Tokyo Olympics.
Oh gosh, this is too real.
Organizers promise it will happen soon, but no reason...
No.
No cure.
50% complete.
Guys, we're in trouble!
We're in trouble, we're in trouble, we're in trouble.
I can't scramble anymore.
Wait.
No.
Maybe devolve?
Devolve.
These are fine.
We...
We've already spread to the places, right?
So we should be okay.
Paralysis!
Alright.
Oh my gosh, it's still going up so fast!
Killed... Wait, it's already...
How has it killed so many people?
I thought we only killed one person.
I mean...
Oh gosh, we're at 60%.
There's no healthy people left!
Okay, now we can get rid of the transmission stuff.
Devolve.
We need more points.
We need more points!
Everybody has a brain rot.
Everybody has the brain rot.
Okay, symptoms.
Coma.
How many do I have?
I'm only at 14.
Devolve the weak early symptoms.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I feel like we want insomnia.
We want them to be less productive, right?
Spread the disease.
Okay, let's get rid of the things that spread, right?
And then...
I want the coma.
I don't think we have enough though.
Fatal tumor growth!
What?
Internal hemorrhaging!
That's kind of big.
Which one should we do?
The tumor or the hemorrhaging?
Think of it like this.
It's not a regular tumor and not a regular hemorrhaging, you guys.
It is.
The hemorrhaging is...
Is you just losing all your brain cells.
You know what I mean?
Hemorrhaging.
Okay.
Oh gosh, 64?
No!
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Killed more than Spanish flu!
Yeah!
Give me more points, please!
Yes, please, more points.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I think they are going to develop the cure.
Oh no!
I don't think we are going to make it.
Oh, they are already at 80%.
I have no...
No points!
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
We got the tumors!
We've got the tumors!
Oh gosh, the cure.
What's this one?
Decreases future research speed.
Decreases...
How much is this?
31!
I don't have enough at all.
I don't have enough.
Finland begins to break down!
Brain rot.
No!
Oh no!
The cure!
Oh my god!
It's happening so fast!
No!
My brain rot!
The brain rot to be eradicated.
The world has survived a devastating plague and will soon eradicate the brain rot forever.
No!
Guys, it's not powerful enough yet.
All hail, king of the losers!
We were so close.
Share the news.
My bacteria called the brain rot just got eradicated in 980 days.
Dang it.
Dang it!
No!
Shall we retry?
The brain rot.
Maybe, hold on, let's do like fox die.
Maybe.
Minky virus?
Wait, it has to be in all caps.
Fox die.
It has to be in all caps.
I know!
I fix it!
Fox die.
Where should we start?
I'm going to close my eyes.
I'm going to close my eyes and I'm going to pick a place.
So I'm just going to...
Oh.
Next one should be pregnant.
No!
Sorry, brain rot cured.
Got to sell your patchy slot now.
I will never be cured!
Oh,
I accidentally went over to chat.
You guys are the infected.
Oh my gosh, I keep going off the dang board.
Oh my god, I keep going off the screen!
I'm in the ocean!
Ok, hold on.
Here!
I ran to fox die.
Fox die begins in Iran.
I walk.
Fox die.
And I run.
I run so far away.
Why are we still talking about the Tokyo Olympics?
And I run.
I'll never get away.
Get our DNA points.
Here I'm going to...
How is it so spreading so fast already?
How are there already 18, 20, 21, 22, 20...
Everybody is kissing!
These darn kissers.
I'll punch them in the kisser.
Ok.
Alright.
Let's do...
Let's spread a little bit.
Wait.
It does say, figure out the information about the country, right?
Fox die has infected hundreds.
Wow, there's actual pictures.
Business as usual.
Where is the information?
Ok.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Ok.
Transmission.
Let's see.
Are there bugs or mosquitoes in Iran?
I don't know.
Let's do hot.
Hot temperature.
And transmission.
Maybe livestock?
Rats?
Livestock air?
I feel like livestock makes...
It's also cheaper.
You have a successfully evolved fox die.
There are mosquitoes everywhere but Antarctica.
Lucky Antarctica.
Canadians celebrate Hay-Herbert Treaty.
Canadians celebrate the anniversary of the famous Hay-Herbert Treaty which saw Alaska become part of Canada.
Americans outraged.
What?
Is that real?
Kissing the livestock?
You would be surprised.
Someone's lonely.
Working that late night.
They see that little lamb.
They are like...
That's a soft sheep.
We must take back Alaska.
No, no, no.
No symptoms yet.
We must go under the radar.
This game tries to sabotage me.
For real.
I did see some people saying air.
So you know what?
I'll do both.
Are you a bioterrorist or an angel of death?
I'm mean though.
Yeah, I'm mean phantom.
Very new player thing to do.
Won't work later on.
Hey Vtuber.
Vtuber, you've played this game two times already.
I think you should be an expert.
Fox die infecting more countries.
She is in fact mint though.
Yeah, I'm mint phantom.
I'm mint phantom.
More infectious than TV.
Oh shoot.
Okay.
Okay, it's going crazy now.
It's going bonkers.
Is that an infected one?
I don't think so.
Not yet at least.
It was a little landlocked.
But it's spreading, it's spreading.
We're getting into the other places.
Maybe if it gets into India.
Holy moly.
Almost everybody in Iran is infected.
And there goes everybody.
And that's the whole country.
It's very slowly infecting the other places.
We do also need to get into the colder places.
So let's evolve with the cold resistance.
And let's do this one as well.
All this disease talk is making me sick.
Love sick for you.
Get some help.
Get some help, clockwork.
No mutation.
No mutation without compensation.
Nice, nice, nice.
The spread, the spread, the spread.
G-S-H.
Get well soon.
G-W-S.
G-W?
Alright.
You know what, we'll make it go faster.
We will make it go faster.
It's scary though when it goes fast.
When there is, you know...
When there is the...
What's it called?
Human countries have more rainfall.
When they start getting to the cure stuff, you know.
Oh my god.
Guys...
Um...
New cleaning techniques are now being used to stop ships transmitting any diseases.
Oh no, Madagascar.
Only advanced waterborne diseases can survive on them.
Okay, we need to...
We need to do...
Evolution.
I'm going to get rid of the sheep.
Goodbye, sheep.
You were 10 points.
Ouch.
Okay.
Upgrade.
Let ships be infected again.
I did it.
I worked.
I like how it shows Alaska even though it meant Canada.
Okay.
Nice.
Let's do...
Oh, we got Madagascar.
Okay.
Still no New Zealand.
And we also have...
Iceland, but not Greenland.
Don't... For this, should it be...
Wait.
D-G-W-E.
Don't get well ever.
For this, maybe.
All the get well cards that you would buy at the store, they're outlawed.
We won't allow it.
Oh shoot.
Okay.
What happens after MGS4 game is over?
I cry.
Okay.
I cry and just think about MGS4 some more, honestly.
Insomnia.
Is insomnia okay to have?
Maybe it makes people a little less productive.
I think that one is okay, honestly.
New minor disease.
A doctor in Saudi Arabia found a new disease which has been named the Fox Die.
It appears to be mostly harmless.
Yeah, it is mostly harmless.
What?
No.
Already?
They're working on a cure already?
We still have so many countries we haven't even gotten.
So many.
We need more cold.
Not that kind of cold.
We need more this cold.
Evolve.
Tokyo Olympics back on.
Let's go.
Greenland.
Help the Olympics go viral.
Yes.
Go to the Olympics.
Go to the Olympics and get the fox.
We got New Zealand.
Let's go.
Yes.
Maybe...
No sir.
Yes sir.
We need also...
We need these ones.
Increase effectiveness.
Here we go.
I have to save... I have to save... What's it called though?
I have to save disease points.
I have to save disease points for fox die.
Maria, I'm not asking for help right now, but...
If I ask for help, then you can tell me some advice.
But right now, I just kind of want to try and figure it out on my own.
Fox die.
Jet die.
I was West Africa, so...
Devolve.
This one's also only two points.
So you get back what you make.
I don't want the nausea yet.
I don't want them to think it's so dangerous yet, you know?
How is Canada still not... Do we need that much coal that we have to get?
Like these countries are...
Yeah.
Oh, we haven't even gotten... Okay.
Yeah, cold resistance.
Yeah, I think so too.
I think I need to... Maybe against all climates.
Maybe I do this one.
Let's see.
Fox die on the weirdest day.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, we're already at 11%.
I just noticed.
Okay, but we've hit every country.
Alright.
But we still need to...
Vtuber advance to the feudal era.
I'm still worried about... Look, look, look.
It's now really catching up here.
Oh my goodness.
I checked and fox die is six times better at infection than COVID.
Mates confirmed to be more dangerous than normal viruses.
Fox die is placed on the who.
Although not very dangerous, governments warned that a more deadly strain could appear.
I'm scared.
No!
No cure.
No cure!
Oh my gosh.
You can shut down your airports, but you are already all entirely infected.
Wait, how did you fly there if you shut down the airport?
Already 25%.
Holy moly.
Okay.
We're gonna scramble.
No!
Started fox die mint as Naomi.
How dare you insult me like that.
What?
Already?
Wait, how did you sequence it?
I just scrambled it.
How did you sequence it?
I scrambled it.
I scrambled.
Oh shoot.
Points, but...
No!
At least Naomi looks good.
What are you saying?
Start getting lethal?
Okay.
Paralysis.
Coma.
Total organ failure.
No cure.
Okay, bye bye everybody.
Goodbye.
Fight the cure.
Wow.
Some of the countries are really holding out.
Oh my gosh, the pop-ups are kind of annoying sometimes.
I think we need to go even further.
Iceland begins to break down.
No, no.
Oh my goodness.
Rash symptom mutated, nice.
Okay, alright.
Let's spend.
Does the genetic hardening and stuff even work anymore, I wonder.
Or is the reshuffle better than the hardening?
It slows research.
Ah, I see, I see.
Is that Elp asking?
I am.
If you kill faster than infect, you can also lose.
True, true, true.
Why not both?
I don't think I have enough for both.
I'm gonna try the reshuffle.
I think.
Hardening is usually better than shuffle?
Really?
Okay.
Anarchy!
60%?
Holy cow.
No, no, no, no.
Guys, I think we are donezo.
Guys!
No!
Please, please.
Nuclear meltdown?
Oh my gosh, huge nuclear explosion in Central Europe.
I got an achievement for that.
Holy cow.
Okay, I have 80 points now, let's see.
I am gonna do this too.
Reshuffle?
Maybe that was dumb?
I don't know, but...
I'm trying to find the ones that say, like, makes it harder, you know what I mean?
More dangerous in cold countries.
Sweating.
Infect?
Okay.
Let's do water.
Maybe bird.
Infectious lethal.
Maybe we can just do all of... Actually, no, I don't have enough for all of these.
Transmission and mutation.
Based on Stalker, I think the last... What's it called?
The achievement I just got was a Stalker reference.
Okay.
Oh, the cure has significantly slowed down.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Well, I said that.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's still really slow and... Wait, oh, that's why it's... Wait, huh?
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Does that mean they are all dead or... Wait.
What does that mean?
Oh no.
No, they all... Oh no, I didn't spread it.
Oh no!
No!
I didn't spread it enough there.
And that's why nobody else...
That's why nobody else is becoming infected in Russia too.
I messed up, you guys.
Oh, I messed up.
Greenland is just chilling.
I was like, why are they so... How are they not moving at all?
It's so quiet.
Nobody is traveling at all.
We killed more this time, which is exciting, I think.
But soon we are gonna have killed everybody who is infected.
Try bird?
I already have bird.
Hold on, I'm gonna devolve a little bit.
Give me some more points.
I don't know if the wind would work.
I guess Greenland would be arid, right?
Because it's so cold.
No!
Rats wouldn't be good, I think, because nobody is taking a boat to Greenland, you know?
So, it wouldn't reach.
Yeah, Greenland is locked out.
We got close.
Yeah, I don't think Greenland is possible either, guys.
RIP to everybody.
Like, I can't tell.
Is this just they are all dead?
Or what?
What does... Oh, yes.
It means that they are all dead.
This is messed up!
98%.
Gosh.
No!
Well, I think we are gonna lose Sweden and the Baltic states, but everybody else...
Ah, we were so close!
NT, NT, NT, NT.
I wonder if I could...
Nah, I still don't have enough to do anything.
Yeah, we got Madagascar.
Greenland is so difficult.
Curse you and your... The name that was meant to confuse people.
You think now that we are in the modern age and we know that Greenland is not green and Iceland is not ice that we would switch the names.
You know, to not confuse people.
You think that now we are in the modern era.
We would say, ah yeah, we can make that... We can stop that joke now, you know.
Oh, the Baltic states.
The only one.
Baltic states strong.
Little by little.
I don't think the cure is gonna happen.
I don't know though.
They are still healthy people.
They just need healthy geniuses.
This is a true...
This is a true Stephen King's The Stand moment.
Ripperoni.
Yeah, we didn't get a lot of people left, so...
Greenland just chilling.
Naomi lost.
You know what?
That's the biggest win, right?
Naomi didn't win with FoxDie.
I don't feel so good.
Lilliput, stop being dramatic.
We are in the modern era and we still call them dashboards.
Used to be a board that protected you from mud that horses would kick up when running.
Really?
Like the dashboard of a car?
A car dashboard.
7 billion people ain't too shabby.
Yeah?
Look at them.
Almost 2000 days.
Our genetic complexity was complex.
We got one score out of five.
It's so sad.
My bacteria called FoxDie just died out in 1983.
1983.
The modern mudflap has taken over for the dashboard.
I don't know about you, I still kick up mud in my car.
I think the dashboard is still necessary.
The important thing is that you choose life and then live.
Don't you think, Snake?
The bite of 1983.
Oh my gosh.
It's the bite of 1983.
VTuber can drive?
I can drive.
And I'm a good driver.
I've never been in an accident.
Knock on wood.
I've never even gotten a ticket.
I'm a good driver.
There it goes.
Yeah, but sometimes I have to possess people.
Just because I'm a ghost doesn't mean it's so easy to get places.
You guys don't understand.
As a ghost, I'm mostly confined to my maid cafe.
Because it's like where my soul is tied to.
Ghosty nonsense.
Sometimes it's also easier and faster to get places if I possess somebody.
But if I possess somebody, I have to be able to drive or fly the plane.
Or anything like that.
I know how to do these things so that I can go around.
Otherwise, floating...
The further I get away from my maid cafe, the slower I am.
That's just how ghost stuff works.
You guys are all like, you're a ghost.
You can just fly wherever you want to.
It's not so easy.
I didn't mean to click exit.
What's a scenario creator anyway?
Create and publish your own scenarios.
I launched something.
Hearing a lot of co-print.
My game just froze.
There we go.
Nevermind.
It's an online maker.
Cure mode is the one that you have to get the DLC for.
Which I do not have.
I don't want my oshi inside me like that.
Well, too bad.
I've already been inside you.
And you're gonna just accept that?
Those are the terms and conditions you signed from watching my stream?
You give Mint any time she wants to possess.
You give her the okay.
I trust you.
Must take some real driving skill for you to reach the pedals.
Chovek, what the hell is that profile picture?
Is that you?
Understood, boss.
If you ever... I don't... But don't worry.
If I'm possessing you, I don't like...
I don't like... I don't like... What's the word?
Is oshi drew that PFP?
Fine.
I see how it is.
Just pull out the granite uno reverse card when Mint tries to get inside you.
What?
No.
You can't possess a ghost.
That's not possible.
Say you hate him?
I hate... I hate everybody!
Whatever.
Fine.
I don't have to be your oshi.
I don't care.
I don't care if I'm not your oshi.
Whatever.
Get out of here.
I don't care.
I don't even...
I don't even... I don't even...
I don't even care about it.
Anyway.
Let's start!
Where am I?
I'm in the ocean.
I don't care if you hate me.
Grow my name.
What are you talking about?
Make you love.
No!
Too late!
You'll pay for this in multiplayer Age of Empires.
Yeah, we'll settle this in multiplayer Age of Empires.
Let's see.
Back to Russia maybe.
But you're not my oshi.
You've always been my kami oshi.
Really?
No, I don't want to do Russia again.
You know what?
Greenland.
Let's do Greenland this time.
Chovek, die!
Begins in Greenland.
That is a threat!
Hate isn't the opposite of love.
Indifference is.
Show us your fiery passion.
No!
I don't...get some help Evan.
Heavy!
Sounds like Minto is starting a movement in Greenland.
Yeah!
Wait,
hold on.
I'm missing reading messages.
I'm sorry.
Minto, you didn't mean that right.
I'm shitting and crying right now.
Charging this bat...No!
You're not our oshi, but you're the oshiri.
Are you calling me an ass right now?
So not only am I not your oshi, I'm also a donkey to you?
Zoom!
Die!
Maybe you should turn that anger into love.
No!
I'll never love again!
Love only brings betrayal!
Which means we get Shrek too.
Get oshi'd idiot.
Mass panic over 3D printed robotic juicer?
What is this a reference to?
New robotic juicer banned in 17 countries after UN report highlighted its profoundly disturbing behavior.
Authorities try to restrict access to the CAD file.
What?
Juicero?
What's that?
Hold on, I'm looking it up.
Juicero.
What is the...Oh my gosh.
What is the downfall of Juicero?
Why did Juicero need Wi-Fi?
Why is Juicero so expensive?
What is this?
It was an American company that designed, manufactured, and sold the Juicero Press, a fruit and vegetable juicer.
It featured Wi-Fi connectivity and used proprietary single-serving packets of pre-chopped fruits and vegetables that were sold exclusively by the company on a subscription basis?
No, it can't be this.
I don't think it's this.
It's just saying that it's a 3D printed juicer.
That sounds like the most...
Let me get my fruits and veggies on...my pre-cut fruits and veggies on subscription, please.
Mito getting one guide?
How am I getting one guide?
Like 15 people said it.
But so many people said it.
I was curious what it was.
15 guide.
One guide by 15 people.
True, true.
So many people said the Juicero.
That's craziness.
I'd buy you the Juicero as an anniversary gift.
I don't want that.
I thought you supported DDs.
Are ghosts always this possessive?
Yes, I am possessive of a ghost.
I possess...possession.
Also, shut the hell up.
Ghost, I paid Megatron to sing you happy birthday instead of me.
I was like, wait, you paid Megatron to sing you happy birthday.
Oh no, now I'm going to think about Transformers 1.
Guys, welcome to my membership.
Thank you.
Juicero subscription fee.
We like you possessive.
I...I'm going to get angry for real and you don't want to see me angry.
I'm going to get angry for real.
Chovek is dying and infecting hundreds while doing so.
Stop!
I don't need your love.
I don't even...it's not the love that I want.
It's your unbridled hatred that I would appreciate more than love.
Crash, no!
No!
I don't care what you guys do.
Wait, I didn't want to evolve.
No, no, no.
We're fine.
I don't think it's Juicero.
I don't think so either.
Penny Arcade...wait...Penny Arcade Fruit Effort 2000...Fruit Freaker?
I don't want to get supported.
I hate this.
You enjoy the possessive.
Stop!
Wait, there's...you guys, I'm trying to pay attention to the game.
The age of Matara is over.
Follow me and you will never get free.
I hate this.
Let me and Maddie kind of make the Hayley Joel Osment face.
Don't say Hayley Joel Osment.
This is so messed up.
I'm gonna end stream.
I hate this.
What if I got angry like this and make my face low?
It's not nearly as fun.
Get love bomb.
This is a bad relationship.
Mint's opinions on Western She's GD...
Ignore the haters.
You can possess me anytime.
Cold country is getting colder.
We gotta do stuff guys.
We gotta get the spread out.
It's time.
Our pathogen must be released.
I hate this.
Why am I getting attacked like this?
UK votes for Brexit in...
Too real.
No, this is about FoxDie.
No, this is fake.
This is not real life.
This is fake, fake, fake thing.
No talk of realness.
I think I missed it.
Sorry, Chovek died.
Sorry, my bad.
Fake real life.
No earthquake.
Let's see.
Let's do...
Since we are only boat for now...
We've spread.
We can do...
Let's do water.
The stream is making a bad day much better.
I'm sorry I had a bad day.
Is today Monday?
Tuesday.
For me.
No, no mutation.
No mutation yet.
Devolve.
It's Tuesday.
You know what?
Minto is kind of stinky.
Sure.
When can we start drinking mint juice?
Well, if you use my code...
GamerSups...
You can get my code Boomer.
You can pretend that it's minto juice.
It's Wednesday, my dudes.
Cyber, thanks for 6 months.
Minto Code Juicero.
No.
Oh my goodness.
You think everybody is infected?
Why is it so slow elsewhere?
Okay, we gotta up the ante, everybody.
But we gotta go under their noses, right?
Really kind of under their noses.
They'll never see it coming.
Never see it coming.
I would sell my soul for a Minto wife cup.
It might be more real than you think.
I don't know when it's gonna come out though.
What minto juice tastes like?
I think it would taste like...
I think most people would be like, of course mint juice would taste like mint.
But I don't believe that.
I think I would wanna taste like a melon soda.
Like a melon cream soda, you know?
Trip.
Thanks for nine months.
The festival of love.
Wait, is this now in Norway?
Anybody can have a festival of love.
Melon cream soda is one of the best drinks ever.
Even though I can't have a soda.
I still... I will... I try to drink that.
If I have the opportunity to.
I love melon cream soda.
Minky's melons.
No!
Festival of love is now in Mint's chat.
Are the wisps getting freaky?
In my chat.
I thought you can't drink soda.
No, I can.
I just said that.
I said even if I can't drink soda, I still like to try it.
I drink and I suffer.
Ectoplasm and...
Carbonation does not mix.
Same with me and Derry.
Oh no, that's a little different.
I need to get help just because I proposed a few times.
Says the person who...
Who tried to post themselves in a tiny car and was like...
Hey Mint, isn't this your ride?
Shut the hell up, Evan.
Shut up.
Okay, we made it to Australia.
Still not in New Zealand yet.
Rash symptom.
No, no, no.
No symptom, no symptom.
I feel like I'm...
Let's do air.
Air.
Water.
And the blood to blood.
No, yeah, blood to blood.
Why are you such a hater today?
I don't know.
You are a hater everyday, Chovek.
Shut up.
Get your sassy gay ass out of here.
Sorry, am I too sassy today too?
Sorry.
Maybe I'm the sassy gay ass.
Now I'm fine?
Okay.
Am I spicy today?
Sorry.
Should I be nicer?
It's the ghost in me, you know?
Chovek, calm down.
What does sassy mean though?
Awesome stream today.
Stop.
Stop it.
Okay.
Let's do...
Heat, I think.
We need the hotter climate.
Chovek is living my dreams today.
No, no, no.
Can you be mean to me next?
No.
Mint collab.
Drink at a concept cafe.
Cilantro cream soda?
Do you have the cilantro gene?
The one that makes it taste like a soap?
More infectious than a comical.
Has anybody...
Nobody has discovered it yet though.
Just got infected with spicy mint though.
It's terri...
Oh my gosh.
No, I lost it.
No.
Sacrifice myself and take all the sass.
The acrass.
More like the sass.
Okay.
Nice, nice.
Where are we still waiting on?
Actually, quite a bit.
Quite a bit, quite a bit.
Will you forgive me if I cosplay Raiders in Diablo 5?
I don't know if I will...
Be an off guy.
I would like to try and do like maybe a parking lot meet up or something.
You know, something silly like that.
Maybe if I can like get...
Maybe borrow an iPad from somebody and...
Maybe if somebody wants to hold the iPad or something...
And then I can do a meet and greet in the parking lot or whatever.
Let's forget our panel.
No!
But, you know, that's not accepted, right?
I don't get to meet people there.
One on one.
But you're coming to Dokomi, right?
If you want me at a convention...
To ask the convention.
I've not heard anything from Dokomi.
So I could not say if I'm going or not.
OK.
We're spreading.
We're...
Yeah, yeah.
We're doing well.
How much more?
OK!
We've reached the world!
Let's go!
Let's go.
It's so difficult trying to find a balance between...
Infection and spread, you know, everything.
Trying to get it all together in the perfect balance.
Let's do this one.
So now should hit up more climates.
Look at that!
I think Production Yakai and Oshispark might be hosting unofficial meet and greets.
Oh, maybe.
I don't know.
I've not heard anything.
Why is America...
Oh, I think I need to do this.
Will that help?
Just a little bit.
I won't scatter your sorrow into the heartless sea unless you're Chovek.
I swear to god if we win from this one...
Then I feel a fear.
If you don't appear I won't...
Stop!
Heavy flooding in Brazil?
No!
You're saying we can get Minto at...
Shot show?
What's that?
You know what?
Let's... Wait.
We'll keep the insomnia.
That might be my downfall, but we'll keep it for now.
They finally found it.
They finally started listening into it.
Interesting.
It's more of a Doki Bird show.
What are you talking about?
I play Metal Gear.
Doki only knows...
The killer.
Oh gosh, already?
Oh gosh, okay, hold on.
We can get more spreading in America.
Why is it not doing well here?
No, no, no.
Tokyo Olympics infect Japan.
All because of insomnia.
What the hell?
They're so crazy about it.
Big gun industry show in Vegas.
It was last week.
I want Mint that...
Joe paw.
Joe mama?
Is that a Joe mama?
Okay, let's see.
Let's infect the...
Transmission?
Humid.
Hot climates.
United States is everything.
Joe con...
Joe condies?
What?
That doesn't even make sense.
Oh, make land.
Alright, maybe more infectious now.
With the birds.
Things are pretty heavily infected here.
Oh, choke on.
Wow.
Alright.
Time to ramp up, baby.
Time to...
Ramp up soon.
Okay.
Alright.
No.
Rash symptom.
You know what?
Yeah.
Do it.
Wait.
Russia is like not enough I feel.
I fear.
Let's do... Okay.
Symptoms.
We are going to do coughing.
And we are going to do airborne.
Right?
We are also going to do paranoia.
I like these ones.
They are so exciting.
Maybe time to kill?
Pneumonia.
Maybe it's time for death.
Needs to evolve to kill.
Okay.
We'll evolve to kill.
Sneezing.
Immune suppression.
25%.
First death in Japan.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Maybe I went to cycle mode.
Oh my god!
The cure!
Wait!
Wait a moment.
I only have 30 left.
Okay.
33.
There are no healthy people left in the world!
Full lethal.
That's it.
Ta-da!
Bye bye world!
No.
Sayonara everything.
Oh gosh, 50% already though.
Oh my god!
Everything is happening so fast!
I have no money.
Oh my god.
70%!
You guys, this is not good.
75!
Oh my god.
It's happening so fast.
I need to slow it down.
Okay.
I have 45.
Hold on.
Okay.
Abilities.
This.
Evolve.
I think the symptoms are fine.
I think, maybe.
I don't know which one to buy.
Buy, buy, buy.
But what to buy?
Complete global Minto saturation.
Coma?
Which one?
Where?
That's this one, right?
I don't think I have enough for it.
I don't think I have enough for coma.
Or is this?
Oh this is coma.
I don't have enough for it.
Save for it.
It's a race against the clock!
It's a race against the clock for real.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
I don't know guys.
Oh wait.
Wait.
It's slowing down.
Wait, wait, wait.
I just got the coma.
Genetic reshuffle.
Oh, sorry.
I got the coma.
Maybe we'll get it still.
I think they are all sleeping now.
They don't have enough time.
They can't work on the cure.
Everybody is sleeping.
Oh no.
Wait.
It's going backwards.
Oh wait.
I thought it was at 90%.
Am I crazy?
I need 30.
I need 3 more points.
No way.
There we go.
Resh...
Everybody change places!
OK.
This is it.
Wow, I can't believe we won with this one.
I cannot believe!
Chovek died to destroy...
To
destroy humanity.
Ben, welcome to bamboo ship.
Thank you!
Goodbye everybody in the world!
And nobody is safe from the Brit...oh, points.
Cover idea.
Bad omens.
I don't know that one, but thank you for the suggestion Robert.
Victory!
Wow, exactly 2400 days.
Spite is the most powerful renewable fuel source.
I agree.
Bamboo ship's government has fallen?
No!
Poppy goes so hard.
Is that like P-O-P-P-Y?
I'm Poppy, Poppy.
I went to one of her live shows before.
P-O-P-P-Y.
I'm Poppy.
P -O-P-P-Y.
I think all it took was being Tsum Tsum'd over Chovek's profile picture to win.
I wasn't Tsum Tsum'd.
I was just saying, oh okay, I'm Naichiro Oshii then.
I get it.
This world shall know true pain.
A phantom pain.
Yeah!
All we had to do was start in Greenland.
Wow.
Ionized helix gene type and virus plague type have been discovered and unlocked.
Nice, nice.
I kind of want to try...
The vampire again.
Thank you.
Welcome to bamboo ship.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, I'm new.
Can someone brief me on the lore?
So far I know we're wisps amidst a ghost who doesn't want people to get pregnant.
I can have multiple Oshis.
My heart has place for many tiny angry women.
Who are you calling tiny?
Guys, is this...
That's not what I want to be known for.
He seems pretty caught up.
No!
How about we have a self introduction for many new people.
With some ominous music in the background.
Hello!
My name is Mint Phantom.
I'm a ghost maid.
I love Metal Gear.
I have a cat.
I have two cats.
One is named Paws and one is named Butaro.
Skip Ad, it's me!
What do you mean, Skip Ad?
Nice to meet you.
I'm God Gamer.
And God of bad luck.
And...
You can see which cat was after Brain Rot.
I'm a little freaky.
Sometimes.
I have glasses that show that.
Hold on.
Let me get my glasses.
I'm gonna put them right here on my face.
Then I'll become Freak Phantom.
Hold on.
They are a little messed up.
Plug the Toho Lost Word cover.
Yeah!
I also...
Hold on.
I also did a cover for Toho Lost Word.
The mobile game.
Link in the description.
What else am I like?
What else am I... What else do I talk about?
I really like maids and idols.
I'm otaku.
I really like doujinshi.
Singing?
I like singing.
I like long walks on the beach.
I like...
What else?
Oh my gosh!
I saw someone say dolls.
Hold on.
I forgot the name of it.
But I think I'm gonna get this doll.
You guys.
I think I got... Hold on.
I think I got influenced to get... Oh my gosh.
The Mozu doll.
I think I got influenced to get a Mozu doll.
Have you guys ever heard of one?
No?
Right you freak.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
It's like... They're very... They're very poseable.
And I kind of... They were so cute.
And you can get life size ones.
I think I want one.
You're a comedic genius.
Don't forget that part.
You legitimately caused my face to hurt because I was smiling and laughing too hard.
We're gonna get full three.
If you get one, don't...
Don't style it as mint.
Please.
I mean you could.
I can't really dictate what you do in the bedroom.
But...
Dr.Glorious, thanks for the time gifted.
But you know, it's just kind of...
Hmm...
But...
You know, it's...
It would be so awkward for your friends probably.
I kind of want one.
They're kind of cute.
Ah, so I'm so curious how it works.
How does it work?
Bedroom, what are you planning on doing with that doll?
Posing it, taking pictures.
I'll dress it up.
Anyway, to the new wisp, this is what it's like.
Mint fan have friends?
You guys have friends?
I know you do.
Yeah.
I too also sometimes meet with the people I call friends.
What happens in the box stays in the box.
Oh my gosh, I can put her in a love box.
I can put her in the minto box.
That I have.
Someone gifted it to me.
Wisps are my friends.
I love that.
Yeah, even though I get a little like, wow, you guys are having so much fun.
I see you guys hanging out and going to cons, but not going to the convention.
But sitting in a room and watching my stream.
And I'm like, ah, you guys are hanging out without me.
And
I'm stuck at the maid cafe.
You know, not dusting cobwebs.
They make a 150cm mozu doll, so you can make a 1.0067114094 scale min...
Don't do the math!
Why would you do the math?
No!
Aren't we hanging out right now?
Okay, yeah, we're hanging out right now.
Nine months, I appreciate Minto and my fianc.
Is your fianc also a V?
Parasocial.
So, I'm paranormal.
Wait, Minto, there's a doll from Kika Goods that looks just like you.
Really?
Hold on, I'm looking it up.
Kika Goods.
It's UF doll Doremi Banzers.
Oh my gosh!
Wow, it's actually so cute!
Wait, it actually looks so much like me!
Wait, you weren't kidding!
Oh my gosh, it's so cute!
It's a ball joint doll blind box though.
What?
I need this!
I need it!
Oh my gosh, it looks so much like me!
The ears and everything!
You guys could get this and then you could dress it up.
Wait, I'm gonna get this.
Can you show it to us?
Oh, I googled it on my phone.
Hold on, let me...
Here, for those who are watching on their phones, let me google it on my computer.
UF doll Doremi Banzers.
I'll show you, I'll show you, I'll show you.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Sorry, I'm seeing the pictures still.
And they're driving me crazy!
What?
Wow!
I'm not original at all, huh?
Right, we need to get her a Minto outfit.
We do!
Oh my gosh, these are so cute, I've never even seen these before.
Thank you for introducing me to them, they're so cute.
Make the doll stream on your days off.
I wish.
Okay, hold on, I'm saving the picture now.
I just found a good one.
Look, look, look, look, look.
Even down to like the hair vents and everything.
Look!
This is insanity!
Your mind is original?
I don't even think that.
Look at that!
What the heck?
It could be me, it could be my sister!
Here's my formal invite to you to watch Mint Phantom play Plague Inc.
I won't stop until every brain is haunted by Minto together.
Would you like to join?
Yes?
No?
Sounds boring, different game please.
It's so crazy!
I want it so bad, it's so cute.
I want it so bad.
Can I ask out your sister?
There's also a lilac one.
There is and she's tan.
I saw it too.
Wait!
This is on!
Wait, it's the blind box though.
Oh wait, nevermind, she's not tan.
Sorry, I was looking at a different character.
Oh my gosh, there really is a lilac one.
It's the blind...
What if I bought one and I opened it on stream?
And then we could see if I...
Oh, you have to build it even.
Wow, that's crazy.
Oh my god, someone got her in the...
Oh, she's broken.
Oh my gosh, she's naked.
Don't do that!
Anyway, back to the game.
Sorry guys.
Back to the game.
This doll will now be going out of stock courtesy of Wisps.
Let me get one first though.
Let me get one first please.
Shadow plague.
Gene discovered.
Insert.
Oh, I don't have that gene.
Good enough.
Welcome, Fintmantum.
I hate that name!
The autocorrect turned off IRL too.
I sometimes bite my tongue.
I think my tongue is too big for my mouth.
I think my tongue is too...
I think it's too big for my mouth.
I saw a thing the other day about cutting off the thing underneath your tongue if it's too big.
But I can't tell if it's too big.
Hold on, I'm gonna take a picture right now.
It looks average.
Should I post it to Twitter?
Is anybody a doctor?
Would you be able to tell me if it's too average or not?
Tug reveal?
No, it's under my tongue.
It's the little piece under your tongue that kind of keeps it held in place.
But some peoples are too... posting frenulum.
Yeah, that's what it's called.
Some peoples are too big and so they get them cut.
And mine... I don't know.
I think mine is normal.
If you didn't get it cut off as a baby ghost, you don't need it cut off now.
It's like a pee pee.
My wife is a vet tech.
She'll help.
She would be best because I got that dog in me.
Let's be a vampire.
I'm gonna try casual.
No, I'm gonna do normal.
I'm not a baby.
Nox Eternus.
Minto.
I'm not a tongue doctor, but I am a registered podiatrist.
So if you ever have any health issues with your feet, just send feet pictures to my inbox.
Annie T.
Oh no, Nano, your account got hacked.
That's what happened to me as a baby.
I had a lisp most of my life because of it.
Wait, no way.
Um, hold on.
Freak virus.
Oh my gosh, the V kind of looks like a Y, so it looks like Freaky Iris.
I can vouch.
I trust him.
Very true.
Feetman hacked you.
Freak virus.
Freaky Iris.
Mint your freak inhibitors.
Did you skip that shot?
I'm OK.
Something is working.
I thought I said something is wrong.
Centuries ago a human chose to...
Chose to death?
I chose to death.
Oh my gosh, what do they choke to death?
I think...
Oh close!
Close!
Sorry.
I chose.
I chose to death.
A human close to death was infected by a sentient pathogen, the Shadow Plague.
Buried deep underground, the human was slowly consumed and transformed.
Oh my gosh, such a freak.
Nosferatu.
You guys.
Oh my gosh.
Speaking of movies, I wanted to watch Wicked the other day.
Did I tell you guys this?
I wanted to watch Wicked the other day and I went to go rent it and it was $30.
Rent.
To rent the movie.
Not to buy it.
It was like, actually it was more like $25.
But still, just to rent it.
And I checked on YouTube and I checked on Amazon.
Just to rent the movie is $30.
Like holy what?
It was only 5 more dollars just to own it.
Just to rent it.
I don't like Wicked that much.
I might be, I might be, I might be, I might be coming pirate 5.
Oh, 5, thank you for the dono.
I was like, that's actually stealing.
Because you also only get to have it for like 48 hours, you know.
That's insanity.
And I was thinking about renting Nosferatu too.
Free at your local library.
Really?
I have a library card.
I get freaky books from that.
Bro is down bad.
What are you saying?
I didn't see it.
If your tongue is too large for your mouth, you can keep it at all.
I don't want to read that.
I don't want to think about it.
Choose where your vampire emerges.
The shadow plague has fully mutated the DNA of its host into being a great power.
Now driven by eternal hunger, it is time to rejoin the world.
This time, humanity will fall.
Too lewd.
I think all vampires would come from Australia.
Yay or nay?
It's the eucalyptus trees.
Nay?
Why?
I don't know.
I just thought that.
Australia is so sunny.
Then England.
She might be right.
Down under is closest to hell.
See, you get my vision.
The only vampire movie that ever caught my attention was the Lost Boys.
I strongly recommend it.
Big Boss even stars in it.
Eucalyptus!
Oh my gosh.
We have to start there.
Eucalyptus literally joined the membership.
Have you seen what we do in the shadows?
I have.
I love that show.
I've seen the movie too, but I like the show more.
Eucalyptus.
A vampire rises in Australia.
Can we name the first two vampires Remilia and Flandre?
Flandre?
Yeah.
The vampire is out here boxing with kangaroos.
Oh yeah.
Vampire.
What is he gonna do?
Gonna chill.
Shadow blessing.
The vampire releases the shadow plague to help subjugate humanity.
Victims develop severe bruising.
The picture is so cool.
He's coming for my neck.
Oh my gosh.
Edward Cullen.
What's this one?
Vampires feed by drinking blood while they're still alive.
Night Wraith.
Vampires adapt to the modern world and is able to feed much more stealthily.
I think stealth is good.
Makes it harder for humans to detect vampires.
This is a weird episode of Steve Irwin.
Your vampire can change the world.
Your vampire is shown as a red icon on the world map.
It has unique powers and abilities, so use it wisely as you try to cover the world in shadow.
The vampire.
Not the hedgehog.
Hey dad!
We're hungry.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, one purple dot.
Teeny purple.
Teeny tiny purple.
How do we infect them though?
I don't want to just kill people.
I guess...
Allows travel to nearby countries.
Oh, we don't really have that.
We have New Zealand and...
Yeah, we have no spreading.
We're only killing.
I guess we have to do the shadow blessing.
Here it is.
What is this?
Vampiric awakening.
Create a new vampire by temporarily producing toxic mutagens.
Almost all infected will die, but eventually a viable host will be found.
Reusable.
And this mate is the wild Nosferatu.
Oh, sorry I didn't say it.
Crikey, look at that mug.
He's an ugly one.
That's so mean.
He would still appreciate...
The vampire.
He's a beaut.
That's what he'd say.
You're not ugly.
He's just balding a little bit.
But he still got hair strands.
Enough to make a ponytail.
He is pretty ugly though.
Nosferatu!
No, definitely would.
Let's see.
What is this?
Nocturnal.
Infected struggle to sleep at night.
Increases infectivity.
Cys develop.
R1 DNA point.
Infected.
Oh, the freak virus.
I forgot we called that.
Freak virus created by vampire.
I know, the little bats are too cute, right?
The vampire releases a unique strain of the shadow plague called freak virus.
Which spreads independently from the vampire.
Infected humans have no idea what the vampire has planned for them.
But if you turn all of them...
Into vampires, would they not...
Then you have no human food left.
Unless you take some humans...
And you breed them to be your food slaves.
Yeah, human farm, exactly.
Alright, I know you guys would be the first to offer.
You guys would be like, me, me!
Nosferatu!
I'm half vampire, I have a fang, probably.
And I'm a ghost.
Which is...
Like, tangentially related.
We're both undead.
Well, I'm not undead.
I'm dead, but I'm talking.
Close enough, right?
It's like my distant cousin.
One cousin removed.
From a vampire.
We're both French.
Freak virus needs help from vampire to spread.
Your disease is weak and vulnerable.
Your vampire must evolve.
Evolve vampire.
Vampire visits hundreds of humans each night.
Sounds like a plan.
Wait.
Vampire able to create a layer for it to rest and heal.
Also generates DNA.
Infected population increases DNA.
Oh, I like that.
And then, blood rage.
Will attack research military facilities if present.
Oh, that's big!
But, I think we need...
Let's do this one first.
Oh,
I can only get three abilities.
Wait, isn't that all there is?
Yeah, that's all.
Oh!
Oops.
Okay, I understand.
Wait.
No.
You have to be able to...
Oops, sorry.
You have to be able to also transform into a bat.
I like this Walmart...
Sephiroth theme.
It's good though.
Alright, slowly but surely.
Slowly but surely.
The music does go hard, right?
Danish mafia becoming too powerful.
New investigation into organized crime and anti-social behavior.
It's very slow.
Okay, we need him to go infect the hundreds.
Okay, off you go.
Off you...
I think he opened his mouth a little bit.
Pastry gangsters.
Okay, now we're talking.
Now we're talking.
Oh yeah, baby.
Nine thousand, ten thousand.
Oh yeah.
Police can't explain brutal murders in Australia.
The work of the world's greatest serial killer.
And the serial killer will go against the Danish mafia.
Serial versus...
It's like a battle of the breakfasts.
Freakferatu!
Serial versus pastry.
Exactly.
How many people are in Australia?
Oh, you have like literally...
Oh, that's 23 million... billion.
What are thou thoughts on pancake frisbees?
Vampire able to meditate and emit the shadow plague in a huge cloud.
Increases the speed at which vampires can heal when in their lair.
Okay, let's evolve so we can head off to other countries.
Everybody don't mind the bat on the plane.
It's just a little guy.
Maybe they'll fly to...
Uh oh.
The vampire feeds by drinking the blood of its victims, leaving behind drained corpses.
It is only a matter of time before the humans realize that they are dealing with something far worse than a murderous cult.
What is a ghost?
But a miserable pile of expired blood bags.
No, no, no.
You say ectoplasm at least.
How do you not get caught?
Let's see, okay.
The vampire is on a track during blood rains, enters a trance, and let it heal whilst feeding from people.
Victims develop additional muscle... Oh, increases infectivity.
Let's get our infection up a little bit.
Looking pale.
You're gonna be strong and pale, baby.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
This one's so tricky.
Because there's just so many already dead, you know?
We already have 300 dead!
From one guy.
Is 300 not enough for you?
Quench your thirst, mister.
It's been one day!
He's hungry.
He hasn't fed in... how many years?
Make a lair?
I did, I did, right?
This one?
Yeah, we have a lair.
We need to build up our stuff.
What's the virus we're spreading again?
The freak virus!
The freak virus.
Any bats gonna travel around?
To New Zealand, perhaps?
No?
Okay.
Build lair with a button.
What button?
Right in here.
Hidden away from humans, this lair acts as a base for the vampire.
Here it can heal itself away, as well as generate DNA by conducting genetic experiments on healthy and infected people.
Can I fly?
No?
Fly?
Let the world know of the freakiness.
Oh, that's how it generates.
Oh, fun.
Okay, that's a little bubble we gotta click.
Wow, Antarctica!
I went to... I went to around here.
It's not so exciting?
Anything?
Anything on the news?
Grieving mother blames vampires.
Blogger claims vampires are real.
Nobody listens to them.
We're fine.
We're fine, we're fine.
I've never seen polar bears, because those are in the north.
Blood cult leader tracked in Australia.
Authorities in Australia have confirmed that they are tracking a highly dangerous individual who they believe is responsible for the horrifying blood cult murders that have shocked the world.
But we're not a blood cult, we're like a...
We are a vampire.
Okay, we only have 12.
This is rough.
What the heck?
Blood to blood contact.
Genetic shift.
Increases infectivity.
Cross-species infection?
Okay, let's try that.
Not in the dogs.
Oh my god, that's so sad.
Handshake!
Survives outside the body, transmitted via external objects.
People love to shake hands.
They're totally going down.
Vampire dog.
Weird ad.
What are you saying?
This cootie's infecting world domination stream is sponsored by...
No!
Wrong!
It's not!
Australia is tough, guys.
Australia maybe is not the perfect place for a vampire.
Maybe it's actually much tougher here than I thought for a vampire.
Um...
Literally we've infected...
Nothing else.
Oh, pheromone secretion.
Mutated and developed the pheromone secretion symptom.
What is that?
Do you smell sexy?
Oh my god!
Making victims more charismatic and able to easily manipulate, seduce others.
No way!
See, we don't have the photophobia yet.
Almost all infected will die, but eventually...
Oh yeah, that's right.
We don't have enough for this.
And also, I think it would be bad to kill off everybody.
Riz pheromones.
That's insane!
Is that why...
Vampires are supposed to be so sexy and everything?
They give off...
They give off like a sexy...
Charisma.
We can get more...
No, not here.
Here, right?
I can't afford anything though.
I can't afford anything.
Infection is quite slow.
Oh wait, I'm also on slow time.
Now we're on fast time.
My bad, I didn't realize we were on such slow time.
We have to cover all of Australia.
And then...
You'd think that it would transmit eventually.
Oh, let humanity discover your vampire.
Oh shoot.
Templar Industries reveals global vampire threat.
Who the hell are you?
Guys, I think it's over for us.
Secretive multinational defense company reveals that a vampire is behind the blood cult murders that have shocked the world.
Get inside your lair!
Vigilantes in Australia fight vampire!
Who is a vigilante?
Activate military protocols!
They're coming for us.
They're coming for us!
How the hell do you beat this?
What if I...
What's this?
Dark pustule.
Harder to cure.
Zoom out.
They have HQs.
Oh my god.
They do.
Attack!
Kill!
I can't get there.
Wait, what's this one do?
Create a lair.
Send the vampire to another country.
I can't do that one because we're too far away.
I can't.
Oh no.
Look at their bombing.
They're trying to kill us off.
OK.
Oh gosh.
This one though...
Attacks research facilities if present.
Otherwise goes on killing spree.
I'm gonna go on a killing spree?
Unknown disease.
This is the freak virus.
You're using it wrong.
I'm trying to...
I am not... This is my first... Well, this is my second time ever playing this one.
Drones!
Oh my god.
Not the lairs.
Wait, make a new lair!
We can't.
Oh, we're so done.
Our lair...
Oh my god!
Heal in there!
What did that one say about Iceland?
I don't know.
Templar.
Oh gosh.
Freak virus placed on a watch list.
Good, good, good.
We have 26 points.
Let's...
Let's see.
Tens of thousands.
We need more infections.
You know?
Doubles the size of their wingspan.
When traveling vampire is able to instantly travel to... Oh, any lair.
Shoot, we don't have that yet.
Okay, let's do this and also maybe our wingspan.
Bat.
Fly.
Fly?
Bat.
Fly.
Oh gosh.
Nevermind.
I'm on a watch list.
No, not me.
Working to cure the freak virus.
It's only... It's barely infected anybody.
Only 6 million people.
Not even half of Australia has it.
Come on, man.
I have to select the vampire first.
Hold on.
Wait, how do I select the vampire first?
Oh, that's how it works!
Oh my goodness gracious.
That's how it works.
Travel.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, we could have been traveling this whole time.
Oh, sorry.
If you said, please don't...
Now they won't know where we are.
Oh.
La.
More infection.
Ha.
La.
Yeah!
We've left Australia!
Let's build a lair here.
Let's build a lair everywhere, actually.
Let's build a lair wherever we can go.
They won't ever know where we're at.
Wait.
They'll never know.
Oh shoot, I missed the...
Oh wait.
I can't build.
How many can I have?
Oh, it's 11 dollars.
Never mind.
That's expensive.
What?
It's a dollar per flight?
Oh, I'm just wasting money.
Stronger than USA!
Oh no.
Uh oh, some places have already shut down their airports.
Wow!
Oh my god!
They blew up my lair.
Lair destroyed in New Zealand!
No!
It's okay, people are still getting infected.
Oh gosh, I forgot about the cure.
This one is so tricky.
This one is hard.
Now I know how to travel and stuff.
Let's see.
Vampire...
How do I scramble it?
Slightly harder to cure.
I don't remember how to scramble.
Shoot.
It plays so differently.
It really does.
You have to be...
So...
Who lab close to developing cure for freak virus?
Oh gosh.
Attack this place?
Wait.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
It's so strange.
Lab in China destroyed by vampire!
And I'm gonna set up my lair here too.
No.
Wait, how does a vampire laugh?
Sexily and scarily.
Do I sound sexy?
Am I sounding sexy?
Oh gosh.
Cures poison vampire in China.
Oops.
Goodbye.
Everybody is dead in Australia?
No, that's not possible.
Vampire slain in China!
Wait, that's me.
I'm the vampire!
No!
That's me!
Vampire!
We had not good run.
Your laugh sounds very cute.
Thank you!
This is so goofy guys.
We spread the brain rot.
We spread fox die.
We spread Chovek die.
We spread freak virus, but only one prevailed.
Now you can try with abilities from the start.
No way.
No, I have nothing unlocked.
Unless...
I don't know.
It's okay though.
Maybe another time.
This was fine.
I had a good time.
I hope you guys had a good time with this silly game.
And yeah.
Mint is too nice to spread plagues?
Oh yeah?
Get real close.
Get real close to your screen.
Get really close.
Get as close as you can to the screen.
Get really really close.
Get as close as you can.
I'll get even closer.
Get really really close.
Ready?
I spread freak virus to you!
You have been infected with the freak.
Down with the sickness?
No, no, no.
Down with the freakness.
You missed...
Have a freaky night and freaky dreams!
Thank you!
Bye bye!
You
guys want to see something funny?
My glasses have more jiggle physics than me.
Oh yes, yes, yes!